wearing a parka over a suit is both a  very easy thing and a very difficult  thing wearing a park over suit should be  saved for those really D slushy and  Clement days of winter the parka is a  great solution when it gets cold and I'm  telling you the city living in the  winter is freezing cold and there's no  reason why it can't be practical and  stylish at the same time wear the parka  to really live up to your business suit  it has to be a couple inches longer than  your jacket but also it needs to have a  neutralist to it and this is not the  time when you want to wear a parka with  different colored sleeves or a pattern  this is a time when you want to wear  something that's going to look like you  meant to throw off your style you meant  to break the rules  you